so all the Avengers are either dead or
retired and the world has gone to crap
how's that for an intro now the ending
of this video is going to blow your mind
but this is Avengers Twilight and this
opens up with Captain America or really
more just kind of Steve Rogers right
just waking up in really kind of his
apartment which is in a lot of ways him
just kind of reliving the past right
like a Captain America mug and the
American flag on the back and all that
kind of stuff in some ways this story
for those of you guys who saw our video
on it it will feel a lot like earthx
right it'll feel very very similar to
earthx but the kicker about all this
right of course Captain America is
married to Rosie really just Steve
Rogers married to Rosa but he has one of
these things where like in the
background there's kind of like a poster
where he was running for Senator but
he's older and he's just kind of run
down if you guys ever read House of M
it's very reminiscent to that version of
Steve Rogers right the one who does not
have a super soldier serum and so as
he's kind of like walking through this
city which is kind of looks very
technologically advanced and so on and
so forth right somebody kind of runs up
on him right he's like are you Captain
America like the original Captain
America and this guy's like yeah you
know like Steve Rogers is like yeah you
know and they're like I mean would you
mind and he doesn't quite let him finish
the sentence and he ask them if they
want a selfie and they say no like of
course not I would never do something
like that and he's like okay you know
it's just my memory is not quite what it
used to be and ultimately ends up
walking away only to come across Luke
Cage now there is a reason why that
encounter between the two of them is so
weird and why they avoid the idea of
cameras because there is a big thing
that goes on here this place is much
much darker than it originally appears
now Luke Cage himself is just an older
and grizzled guy right he still has his
Bulletproof Skin to a degree but we're
actually going to learn this a lot more
about him than we are initially
introduced to here the other thing is
that as the two of them are making their
way through the park of course there is
a lot of kind of celebrating the idea of
superheroes right like people throwing a
Captain America uh frisbee which is
designed of course to look like the
shield and things along those lines but
they end up coming across Matt Murdoch
now one of the things they do talk about
is something called H day right hero day
as it's kind of explained here which
seems to be why there's kind of a lot of
celebrating and so on and so forth again
just because the art style is a little
wonky and we're not really able to make
out like the exact details of everything
but one of the cool things that happens
is that the between Luke Cage Steve
Rogers and Matt Murdoch Daredevil
they're all just older guys now
regarding the idea of like cameras and
things like that while it is a kind of
off-handed remark and we will learn more
about this later on Matt Murdoch makes
reference to something called The
Watcher act which basically makes it
illegal to record and so every kid out
there with a camera phone is kind of
being branded as a criminal right and
Matt Murdoch of course maintaining his
role as a lawyer is helping to like
defend them right things like curfews
and so on and so forth we're not really
getting like the inner complexities of
it but we are getting these little
tidbits that are dropping to us that are
basically kind of pointing out this idea
the country is very very totalitarian
right no cameras curfews there are
always these eyes that are watching them
and in a lot of ways they kind of talk
about their place in this world right
now again it gets really cool this is
just kind of setting the stage but they
talk about their place in this world and
one of the things that goes on here is
Matt Murdoch and Luke Cage kind of have
a role to play in the sense that Luke
Cage is very very fast and loose about
answering the question like what do I do
you know and that kind of a thing he
says that he's really just kind of an
exm mayor which is actually what was
going on and is going on in Marvel
Comics at the time like right now Luke
Cage is mayor of New York City in Marvel
so of course this taking place in the
future seems to take place in the future
of the main Marvel Universe we don't
know for sure right and honestly I
wouldn't really fixate on that fact too
much but the other thing that Captain
America points out here is that he does
not have the super soldier serum and
that while Luke came and Matt Murdoch
are saying like somebody needs to be
like a symbol of Hope right and kind of
show people that the world can be better
than this the response of really Steve
Rogers in a lot of ways is people voted
for this right like people don't want
change like every year or every four
years or however long they go to the
polls and they vote to keep life this
way but the bigger point that Luke Cage
and that Matt Murdoch are making here
even if they're only making it kind of
under the radar is are they really
though right like do people really have
a choice of how this world looks and so
here's one of the cool things that I
want you to notice here right one of the
things that I want you guys to to kind
of pick up there's how Captain America
sees the world how Steve Rogers sees the
world then there's how the world really
is and seemingly Luke Cage and Matt
Murdoch kind of have their ear to the
ground and their nose to the ground
they're actually in it day in and day
out Steve Rogers is almost kind of up
there in his quote unquote Ivory Tower
not in the sense that he's living this
life of extravagance but he's got like a
beautiful wife that he's married to and
his life is far more cushy than the
average person's and so in a lot of ways
it paints this picture that Captain
America is kind of disconnected from how
the world really is and it's a great
analogy right it's a great comparison
here it's not to tear down Steve Rogers
but historically speaking that's kind of
always been the case Captain America
even being a man out of time and being a
leader of the Avengers and things like
that was always thrust into a world that
he never fully understood he did his
best to understand it and he tried to
cope with it but it wasn't his world and
so on some level there was always a
disconnect between the world as it
exists and Steve Rogers in the world
right given hero escapades and so on and
so forth it was usually completely
irrelevant right in this instance it's
totally relevant here because one of the
things that we find out is of course
Steve Rogers had ran for Senator and the
people had shut him down the people
voted against him they were like nope we
do not want you as a senator we don't
want you in any kind of political
position and that's really kind of where
he ended up and so even in a
conversation with Rosa right his wife
when he's back home he's kind of talking
about the idea that like Luke Cage and
Matt Murdoch want him to not necessarily
go back to being a hero in the
traditional sense but to like stand up
for something right to like use his name
for a greater cause Beyond himself but
even Rosa kind of asked a question so
like they want to slap an A on your head
and they want to put you in blue tights
and send you out there into the world no
no no no you can do a lot more and have
a much greater effect by just using your
name and the Really the recognition that
comes with it as opposed to like Dawning
a uniform right because again heroes are
not viewed favorably in the world
anymore at least not the way that they
used to be again all this information
kind of comes small but one of the
things that happens while they're eating
dinner is an advertisement comes on TV
for a docu series called red between the
lines it's this whole docu series about
the Red Skull that what was actually
happening here and we had to kind of
blur out words because YouTube's
algorithm demonetizes stuff because
YouTube's lazy but thing here is that
this docu series paints this picture
that the Red Skull was actually trying
to bring down the Germans from within
and that guys like Captain America and
people like that were actually
hindrances in what he was doing they
were problems they were making life
harder right it's painting this picture
that the Red Skull was a good guy and
guys like Captain America were more of a
nuisance than anything else it
completely and totally blows Steve
Rogers mind because he's like why in the
world would anybody believe that and
when he goes back to room and he kind of
takes out a picture of the old Avengers
team he's just kind of like nobody cares
right like nobody really cares and what
you get is this kind of flashback moment
and in fact we're going to get several
of these over the course of this video
but you get this flashback moment where
the Avengers managed to stop a hydr bomb
plot right to just detonate stuff and it
puts on this idea this air that the
Avengers almost kind of seem like uh
like Hollywood types to a degree not
truly but kind of like looking at
Captain America for example right just
his haircut his uniform all that kind of
stuff I wouldn't go so far as to say
he's like a homelander type character
right owned by a corporation but he
certainly looks the part of kind of like
putting on the show right like the new
Warriors leading up to like Civil War
right like that era of comics for those
of you guys who were are unfamiliar with
it but the bigger Point here is what you
end up doing is switching over to Stark
Industries and you do not pick up with
Tony Stark instead you pick up with a
guy by the name of James Stark who's
actually being taken care of by the
brother of Jarvis right so a lot of the
characters that we know are kind of out
of here more so than that we end up
learning that James is actually the son
of Tony Stark and Janet vany but unlike
his father Tony Stark who was kind of a
billionaire playboy but usually trying
to do the right thing James is far more
corrupt than Tony Stark was more so than
that we end up finding out that
apparently there's some kind of a border
Skirmish between lvia and Hungaria and
so the president of the United States
requests that James starts building more
Iron Man suits are developing more Iron
Man armor that could be given to
soldiers to use in the fight overseas to
kind of quell this Skirmish that is
something that I do want you to keep in
the back of your head but one of the
things that happens here is that James
is told by his Butler the FBI have
informed me that we may need to talk
down an old friend so the FBI is more
like a spy agency right like spying on
its own citizenry and so what you do is
you pick up with a kind of news report
or a kind of interview between James and
Captain America whereas these guys are
talking really Steve Rogers we should
just start calling him that whereas
these guys are talking that James kind
of brings out the idea are heroes really
even heroes you say that you're Heroes
right you say that you guys were Heroes
but H day taught us that there are no
Heroes now this is where we get a kind
of explanation but I would imagine that
as this goes on we'll get a more indepth
explanation of what hday is but the
bigger thing here is that hday was
apparently an event where the villains
seiz control of the Incredible Hulk so
it's not that dissimilar from like uh
Old Man Logan right or ax of Vengeance
right from the 1980s but whatever the
case is the Incredible Hulk under the
control of the villains just started
laying waste to huge levels of the city
and in fact a lot of innocent people
died and what ends up happening is
there's this comment that's made by
Captain America and in fact James even
says it was the day the world woke up
and realized there is no line between
vigilante quote unquote Heroes and media
dubbed villains unparalleled destruction
by all but the death count fell mostly
to Dr Bruce Banner the Hulk was a
founding member of The Avengers was he
not Steve and the response is Steve
Rogers I've said it before it was Ultron
he enhanced the villains took control of
Bruce Banner the response of James yes
Ultron right like the evil AI created
created by yet another Avenger Dr Hank
pimp how are we supposed to believe you
about the Red Skull when you don't even
know what a hero looks like and so it's
one of those things where it just calls
everything Captain America knows into
question now here's one of the big
differences here right and here's
something that I hope you notice right
when it comes to the news as it's
portrayed here there's what the public
perceives the news to be then there's
what the news actually is the public
perceives the news as informative this
organization that exists out there for
the purpose of making sure the general
public is always aware of what's
happening but the way in which the news
actually works in Avengers Twilight is
that it's propaganda right like they
rely on the Public's perception of them
all the while spoon feeding them lies
and then duping the public into
believing that what they're telling them
is the truth and it's just a great big
huge kind of circular organization right
that just runs everything that even
James Stark himself is aware of Captain
America doesn't really seem to
understand how deep reaching it is and
the here and now he's just pissed off
because James called him into question
and is like are you really going to
tarnish the legacies of your own parents
that kind of thing it gets under his
skin right because by and large it's
just James a guy who was never alive or
seemingly never alive during the era of
Heroes never fought alongside the heroes
questioning a guy who was there right
it's very much like a Few Good Men type
thing right like I have neither the time
nor the inclination to explain myself to
a man who Rises and sleeps under the
very blanket of Freedom that I provide
and then questions the manner in which I
provide it I would rather you just said
Thank you and went on your way it's that
kind of situation here right like James
is calling into question everything
Steve Rogers fought for having no real
firsthand account of what it actually
meant to be there and so it's really
really interesting right a guy who's
read about what happened versus a guy
who lived what happened right
experienced would almost always be the
Victor there the thing to understand
though is that reading back on it
historically gives you a much greater
context than the person who lived
through it they live through one part of
it reading about it allows you to
experience the whole thing so which one
of these comes out on top if one of
those things exists at all because
that's one of the points that James
makes right like you as Heroes painted
the world as black and white there's
good guys there's bad guys and the good
guys fight the bad guys and the good
guys beat the bad guys roll credits
right it doesn't work that way right
like if anything was taught to the World
by hday it's that it's never that simple
there's always collateral damage who
thinks about the people who die in the
collapsing buildings when the heroes and
the villains fight you don't because if
you did you wouldn't be fighting them in
highly populated areas right it's all
these kind of back and forth and they
both have credible points calling in the
very nature of all these superheroes but
even when Captain America flashes back
to hday he kind of looks around and he
just sees all these dead bodies Heroes
villains alike and as he's having this
kind of flashback and experiencing this
really you could call it PTSD that we
get this moment where we pick up with
one of the events that had happened and
that it's really just kind of Black
Widow asking the question are there any
updates the response of Iron Man is
nothing yet Natasha just that it looks
like all secret identities have been
blown wide open everyone's being lured
to their loved ones and ambushed groups
of super villains all enhanced the
question of Captain America who's doing
the enhancements the response of Iron
Man I don't know yet cap would need to
actually capture one of these guys to
study them and so once the heroes get to
where they're supposed to be landing at
right New York Spider-Man is one of the
people who are dead right Spider-Man or
at least he's dying anyway but he talks
about how like he had saved the life of
his aunt may he Reveals His identity to
Captain America or at least partially
reveals it and says like my name's Peter
he doesn't quite get the whole word out
the response of Captain America is
you're Spider-Man son right like you're
the best of us and so he has this kind
of flashback it's really cool because
it's like I really want to see what
happened how everything unfolded I'm
really hoping chips sidari just kind of
gives us like this one comic where it
just explains everything just in just
gritty detail but in the midst of this
flashback Captain America's met by cops
right Steve Rogers is met by the cops
who show up on the scene and they
basically tell him hey man curfew is
coming you need to get out of here but
as he's leaving he comes across these
kids who are being recorded while
they're like skateboarding and
Performing trick and stuff like that the
cops are just like so what do we have
here right like illegal recording out
past curfew and so it's just like no man
and where the kids are just like curfew
is not for another 10 minutes this cop's
just like not according to my watch
right like corruption is basically what
it is right corrupt cops abusing their
powers one of the kids calls him a
fascist and Steve Rogers decides to
stand up to these cops now the cool
thing about this is even having no super
soldier serum he is able to Humble these
guys quite readily right because what he
realizes is he says these guys are bozos
right like most people out there who
couldn't get respect if they paid for it
these guys put on suits and it gives
them some measure of authority some
measure of control right a feeling of
strength that can help embolden a coward
but he's like at the end of the day they
are the exact same kind of people that
I've always fought right like I fought
people like this time and time again so
literally he's just like they crumple
like paper that's really all they are
and he manages to take out most of these
guys but of course one of them ends up
getting him getting him over the head
with a billy club and then the rest of
them start attacking him only for him to
be rescued by these guys who just come
out of nowhere and just Pummel these
cops right just absolutely tear these
cops apart and potentially even kill
them we're not really sure if they do or
not but then ultimately they black bag
Steve Rogers right just throw a sack
over his head and whisk him away now one
dark thing that does happen here this is
something that I do want to point out
there Comes This Moment where James
following the orders of the president
goes to the raft in order to find quote
unquote inspiration right to figure out
how to build these new suits when he
gets there what we end up finding out is
that he's got his father in a tank and
that he's basically seeming to use his
father's intelligence in order to build
this stuff we don't know exactly how he
makes it work but he has his father
alive right like Tony Stark is being
kept alive and being used by his son for
information it's pretty screwed up right
it's pretty dark but when Captain
America comes to right switching back to
Steve Rogers when he comes to he wakes
up what seems like an underground
facility only to be met by Luke Cage
because what Luke Cage is actually doing
where he was very clo and Dagger about
his actions and about his efforts where
Matt Murdoch was doing the same thing
because they always knew they were being
watched that he's actually the leader of
an underground resistance or not really
a leader more of like an adviser for an
underground resistance force now one of
the things that we also learn here is
that while Luke Cage did historically
have Bulletproof Skin as he aged his
skin actually started to of Harden to
the point where he couldn't move of his
own accord he needed assistance to be
able to move around but in effect he
tells Steve Rogers Matt Murdoch's dead
right like they took him out he's like
the world that you think you know which
is cops abusing teenagers because
they're staying out too late past curfew
and you know the media putting out some
propaganda that's not the world as it
exists right that's the world as you've
seen it that the reality here Steve is
you are removed you don't really see how
bad it is out there right he's like on
the surface looks fine but there's rot
we're not getting any of the picture
anymore it's a jigsaw puzzle with just
the edges he says the government and
shield are squashing political descent
the new Avengers are laying waste to
countries overseas and the response to
Steve is no there's no way that's true
if it was I would know and the response
of Luke is how the news the internet
It's all under control of a conglomerate
a group that Jan and Tony's kid is a
part of and he says we're trying to get
the word out we've been broadcasting to
find others to spread the truth but it's
not enough we need someone for people to
Rally around and there's only one person
for a job like that and the response of
Steve is like I can't do that Luke right
like I couldn't even protect some
skateboarding kids because the super
soldier serum was taken away from Steve
Rogers he's just an old guy right and so
Luke says you could with this and what
he does is he reveals that they
recreated the machine that turned him
into Captain America right this girl
named Carrie was the person who was able
to pull it off right the super soldier
serum and Carrie even goes so far as to
say like we've been doing our best and
we've been trying to replicate you on
different versions of us but Steve is
just like they keep dying because it
only works on some and there's no
definitive way to know and that's true
right Steve Rogers was just luck of the
draw right if you go back and you read
Ed brubaker's Captain America run one of
the things that he points out is like
there's no way to have known that Steve
Rogers was going to survive it was hoped
by Abraham ersin that it would but he
could have just easily died like anybody
else right it's not like his hope and
his courage was so great that it
overrode the function of the super
soldier serum and it bent it to his whim
right it's not like that right it
doesn't really work that way right he
could have easily been killed but it
does work on him and so their whole
thing is you should take the Super
Soldier serum right like when he tells
Luke Cage you can't be serious he's like
I am right I'm as serious as a heart
attack Steve I don't expect you to be
part of our group of Defenders here
working from the Shadows you're Captain
America you're an Avenger right and
that's where he's just kind of like
Defenders right like this is your group
and the response of Lucas no it's not my
group right I'm too old I can't really
move the way that I used to right ever
since my Bulletproof Skin decided to
become nearly immovable I'm all about
knowledge but given all the experience
that Luke Cage has had over his time as
an Avenger he can impart words of wisdom
on a lot of these younger folks he can
organize them he can Corral them towards
a singular cause he can teach them how
to fight in such a way to where they can
take pot shots gorilla Warfare tactics
essentially right because unlike Captain
America who was the Avenger that was
like off in space fighting the builders
or like facing off against you know
galatis or something you know who knows
the great grandiose type of events Luke
ha was always a street level Avenger
even when he led the mighty Avengers
with like white tiger and uh blue Marvel
Adam Brasher and those guys it was still
very much a groundlevel team and so this
ability to impart that kind of ground
level knowledge on how to hit here hit
there to dodge Bob and weave never get
hit it's invaluable information and so
what luk cage says is that Amy right
this girl here she's the one that runs
everything I may have said Carrie before
I meant to say Amy but he's like Amy's
the one who runs everything right she
for worked for shield she turn coded
right and so Amy Says Matt Murdoch died
defending people who the system was
trying to disappear we've been working
non-stop trying to gain Intel on all of
this people on the inside have managed
to get up photos old school of like all
the different abuses that kind of thing
and she says these are Americans this is
what we're up against it is an American
government corrupt abusing the American
people what Americans need is to one be
shown the truth of what's actually
happening so they stop believing the
lies of the news and then two they need
someone to Rally around it's not to say
that the American people are cowards I
mean on some level sure in comparison to
superheroes but the American people have
a lot to lose if they were to stand up
to their government including their own
lives what they need is a force that
will inspire a level of hope that will
overcome that fear and that people will
say yes I may lose something in respon
to what it is that I'm doing but the
reality here is what I'm getting is
infinitely better and without that hope
they will never take the first step and
so Steve Rogers in realizing this leaves
a message for his wife he says Rosa it's
me I'm sorry this is a message and not
in person I just need you to know I'm
okay I'm more than okay really I won't
be home for a while because there's
something I need to do I'm opening my
eyes and hopefully the eyes of others
but I cannot do it alone and he says
Rosa I'm going to assemble the Avengers
because Steve Rogers enters the machine
he's blasted with Vitas he gets the
super soldier serum back and he goes
back to being Captain America and I got
to be honest guys never have I cared so
much about this guy I am so excited to
see where this story goes but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end again this is coming out
monthly I believe so I think will be
back next month with part two of this
and I will catch you all later
peace